moving the [__] in aspen colorado at the
time was like putting
anderson silva in a [__] karate
school
with a bunch of white belts that's what
it was like i mean
because i tried not to steal i tried but
it's just you have to
you know people leave their windows open
with a purse on the [__] thing and
this is color like i freaked at first
because people say good morning to me
like good morning what [__]
i'm from new york city [__]
don't you good morning me what's so
[__] good about it
you know you don't you're not used to
that [__] like people good morning how
are you
like what the [__] what do you want to
do
and that was like the weirdest because i
really wanted to get my life together
my mom had died i had been in all this
trouble for two years i mean
this was but cocaine was taken over by
83 cocaine was everywhere
you see the weed stores they're all over
california this is the way cocaine was
people were giving it to you even if you
didn't want it you know there was no
more weed
there was no more acid you know i mean
it's so weird when cocaine came because
nobody knew the power of a drug to that
[__] showed up
because for years people did asking and
weed but nobody lost the house
cocaine made you lose houses and you're
wise but people didn't give a [__]
they were freebasing and having a good
time and drug dealers were out
and i went up there and i tried i got a
job as a dishwasher at john denver's
restaurant
and they had this world famous [__]
magician you're not gonna believe this
[__]
and his famous trick was there was a fan
there were fans all over the restaurant
and he would take money from you and put
a card in it with a thumbtack and he'd
have to throw it up
in between the fan say at the end of the
night there'd be thousands of dollars on
the [__] ceiling
i just can't leave it there
so we started taking like a 20 from the
magician me and the other busboys and
[__]
and then they started inviting us to all
these drug parties like these parties at
night
and i had been like a half a burglar you
know already so i got a job i
this built this this complex i forget
what it was called had maybe like a b
c d up to like h and each each letter
was a building
and each of those buildings let's say
they had 12 apartments they had four
drug dealers in each apartment building
so i got a job shoveling snow to case
the joint you follow me
that's what a real pimp does i'd be out
there watching them and [__]
and my buddy my roommate had gotten
thrown out of brown at the time he was
an engineer
so i made him we all had the same door
so i had him devise a machine for me
like a knife with a saw with a hook
that could work on every [__] door so
i would watch the drug dealers go skiing
and i'd go in the house and if they had
an ounce of coke i'd take like an eight
ball i wouldn't even take the whole
thing
so when they got back they're like my
mind's playing tricks on me
and i did that for a long [__] time
but i got [__] crazy in colorado
and i had a i got an electrician job and
this guy that i was working with
he said i could go through any [__]
alarm in the world
so i'm like finally my dream i'm not
shooting a guy
but i'm going to make it as a burglar i
got a partner who's going to teach me
so i started doing it i started reading
up on it and cutting wires and getting
ladders
and had like a little hat with a light
and then it's it's i'm going to go home
february of 84.
it's december of 83. my and by that time
i had tons of money put away
because i was robbing like a different
drug deal every week it was [__]
pathetic
my roommate at the time was from jersey
too he knew what i was doing he's like
joey they're gonna [__] catch i'm
like [__]
watch this this is the smallest
community in the world
and i'm rob robin [__]
so it's christmas eve and it would
happen i would lose my mind when i drank
in those days like i would drink
southern comfort and orange juice
that's what they give [__] indians
before they go to war you understand me
that's the [__] that makes you go
[__] bananas like
and i would have three drinks and i'd
want to rob something
and like instead of a booty call i had
to rob something
and it was christmas eve i'll never
forget this it was christmas eve
i didn't have a girlfriend i was lonely
my roommate was at home
and the mall was shut and i said i'm
gonna rob this [__] mall
so i broke like this tourist store and i
took the safe i couldn't get it open
i broke into this cheese shop stole
cheese
i broke into this other thing and i
[__] and i'll never forget the next
morning i woke up like
like hung over like you didn't know what
you did most people get drunk and suck a
dick or take it in the ass
i would get drunk and rob a house and
forget the next day how [__] crazy is
that
and i'll never forget that i wake up to
my roommate going coax look at the paper
and it said
snowmass village mall burglarized
christmas eve i was like i made the
papers
i cut that [__] out i got a
scrapbook i'm like
damn i'm ready to go [__] i made the
papers
and they had like you know we have
witnesses they had [__] nothing these
[__]
weren't even cops they were just guys in
a sob driving around
but then i had my ball on his jewelry
store the the
the deal was i was gonna rob the jewelry
store and go back to [__] jersey
february for my birthday and have a
great time
so it's a blizzard it's a perfect night
to rob the [__] jewelry store
i go up there with my black little suit
on like bruce lee into the dragon when
he went downstairs remember
i'm [__] tiptoeing tiptoeing
tiptoeing
i get up there i cut the one wire i cut
the other one i go around the back
i'm just about to open the window about
to put my [__] leg in and i look
and i see a sob with the lightsaber with
no siren
they're coming for me so i say [__] this
i take my leg and i run the [__] down
the hill and i'm falling
and i'm stumbling and i run into my
[__] apartment
whoo if i beat him but an hour later the
door knocks
and there's [__] four cops and
they're like uh
how you doing you see anybody suspicious
here and i'm like
have you gone out at all and i'm like no
i've been home all night
like oh there was a robbery it looks
like the guy ran in here
because that the track i left in the
[__] snow
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i'm like nah nah nah nah there ain't
nobody here i didn't leave
and he looks over and there's my shoes
by the heater melting
and he's like something ain't right here
i might listen i know what the [__] you
guys are talking about
you know get the [__] out get out you
got a license you got a warrant no get
out i [__] nobody robbing the house
i'm a cat like i'm 18. i don't know
they knew they [__] knew so i had to
get out of there
i didn't rob nothing for the last three
weeks and i just let it go as
i took it back but i had a bunch i was
robbing and sending back [__]
like i would rob jewelry i knew i
couldn't sell it up there so i would
send it to my friends
and i'd say hold on to the money and
then i robbed this one chick's house and
she had a block of hash guys
with a stamp from the emperor the gold
[__]
that's old school not that [__] they
make up at [__] cold water
and [__] ventura this is the [__]
little arabs making [__] and they stamp
it and they put the thing
and then i brought that back on the
plane with me i'll never forget this i
took a flight united airlines
from denver to jersey and i have this
block of hash and i put a little bit
and i had a wooden pipe in my pocket
with a lighter they didn't care about
nothing those days
you could smoke cigarettes on a plane
and [__] there was a soldier next to me
and i go dawg i got a piece of hash on
me let's go in the back and smoke it
we're in the back of that [__] plane
started smoking that hash they're like
the guy comes on smokingly smoking
marijuana i always [__]
and i robbed the stool this is purse
that's how crazy i was
[__] that [__] there was a purse out i
took the [__] things you got like 60
dollars i threw in the [__] thing
that's how [__] crazy i was at this
time i was like a [__]
one-man parade of thievery
here i am smoking dope with a [__]
soldier on the plane
i'm the plane
what the [__]